hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to markiplier reacts to
teams react to markiplier now a video
was put up on the finebros channel today
or yesterday when you guys are seeing
this and it featured me of all things in
the entire world for teams to react to
so I have no idea what videos they
picked I've intentionally been not
watching it until this moment where I
was able to record it and everyone else
has been laughing their butts off and
whatever the hell they said I have no
idea what it was all about but I'm about
to find out right now so let's get to it
[Music]
they know who I am I'm shocked oh my
face I'm glad they loved my face so much
know who I am
they're giggling he's not gay he's on
booze thank you for dancing I appreciate
a little bit of dancing he's not he's
still not lovable them buds no you can't
[Music]
of course players like my best friend I
don't even know how oh oh this video of
course why this video Jesus
[Music]
of course it's not meant to be got I
added this all in like eight hours
straight and I couldn't stop not the
good part of the internet all way too
many oh man thank you
they take forever oh man I love that
Santa girl made that one like I made all
the other ones but city girl made that
one oh man brings so much happiness to
my life thank you okay so who was that
that was markiplier yeah it was
markiplier you guys he is known as
markiplier markiplier okay now that you
say the name I've heard of the name
markiplier how do you know about
markiplier how don't you know him like
he's everywhere just like spazzing out
I've been watching his videos since like
he barely came out with like the pink
mustache my brother and I always hear
his voice and jacksepticeye's voice yeah
yeah yeah so he's become one of the most
popular gaming channels on all of
YouTube I see why I gotta go subscribe
to this guy hey 9 million subscribers
nice there's rebill ioan views I'm
watching his content why is that because
he's funny he's such a free spirit why
his aura is just perfect he makes you
smile and you don't know why I feel like
whenever I do certain past like that I
will just start rambling and I will sing
songs I relate to this man I see myself
in him I think a lot of people see that
never met a person who doesn't like
markiplier do you watch gaming on
YouTube
not really but in my mind I stereotype
gaming in a way they're all the same you
know I watch like PewDiePie and like I
love super panic frenzy I feel like I
could get into markiplier hit or miss
like it's either funny or it's not funny
YouTube has become so cluttered
ya know this is the only one that
appeals to me we're all different kind
of gamers and de-seed how people like
relate into games like differently it's
really awesome cuz how a diverse gaming
like how you see it from how everyone
else sees why do you think people have
such a difficult time understanding why
it's entertaining to watch other people
play I just talked to Jimmy Kimmel about
this where people are saying like oh why
are you watching someone play it when
you just play yourself I don't want to
spend $40 on a game from not gonna enjoy
it so why don't I just watch other
people enjoy it for me it's kind of like
playing with your best friend I think
it's not the actual game they're paying
attention to it's people playing it it's
not the gameplay footage that's got 23
million subscribers on YouTube it's the
person so when we cover gaming channels
we always bring up that many people are
critical of the content because they
think it's just for kids no way man why
we got a question everything it's not
just these little kids like I know
college kids who like it and adults who
like video games they're not like
actually watching you if they're having
these thoughts and also some have said
that the reactions are over exaggerated
and they're pretending to be scared on
purpose I mean I could see why like they
would say that I think they're doing it
on purpose of it it's not fake it's it's
like a hyperbole of yourself you're
overreacting
but it's still you a lot fans also feel
close to markiplier when he was growing
every 5,000 subscribers he'd make a vlog
thanking people until it became too too
huge to keep up with
but even now he makes very sincere
emotional videos at milestones thanking
them that he never thought he'd get this
far what do you think about that that's
great that's like really great a lot of
shows humbly watch and you can just tell
they're just doing it just like want to
be famous he doesn't have to do anything
for these fans is just putting out a
video every so often once he hits a new
milestone that's great I think that's
the most important staple of YouTube
that people don't really understand
YouTube isn't a gateway to TV or movies
YouTube is a way to form a community
markup ie cries at everyone I went
through like a really depressing phase
my grandfather died I went through a bad
breakup and it really took a toll I mean
his stuff you know kept me above water
and that I'm really grateful for it so
finally markiplier may very well watch
this video so what do you want to say to
mark very humble guy I know man I'm like
speechless here it's so awesome like
think that he might see me you've
brought so much happiness and like times
where I've been though I always watch
your channel oh it always brings me so
much happiness every time thank you
I was like give myself up to be like
okay some people aren't gonna like it
you know whatever oh my god this so
beautiful I need to get in touch with
that guy in the blue shirt what was his
name Lee and Lee go try to find with the
Daniel Daniel 16 year old Daniel Daniel
if you're out there and everyone else
here in the video Darius Daniel Thomas
Kalyn poori
Jasser
Geneva Geneva sorry Michaela will Carlos
and Eric I believe that's everybody I
think I think that's everybody so thank
you all of you who are in this I'm glad
that everyone like really enjoyed this
video like I couldn't believe that
they're like I was like I ever see
people watching my videos so it's so
weird that they watch him and I remember
like the work I put into those
compilations in fact people were
laughing at that that's like really cool
and then of course like I I did a lot of
the older ones and then cyndago help me
with the five nights at freddy 1 which
is the one that they were walking there
watching there and it's just like oh so
cool they actually like that because
when I was watching I was laughing my
butt off even myself and the fact that
other people actually enjoy my videos
and the stupid one where I was walking
down the street and I like for no reason
I just decided Allah throws many memes
into this one as possible I don't even
care at this point that is so so cool I
am tickled to death this was really
really cool so thank you everyone who
watched this and watch my videos and
everyone else that was a part of it
really thank you guys so much and thank
you everyone out there who's watching
now for all the support that you've
given me
uh I I did want to say I am dying my
hair pink because I promised that in the
charity livestream I was gonna if we
reached our goal and I found out that we
definitely are because when we were at
$70,000 out of a hundred thousand Scott
Cawthon the maker of five nights at
freddys actually contacted me saying he
was going to donate enough to get me two
hundred thousand the last minute and the
payment process wasn't working so I am
gonna dye my hair pink I'm thinking of
maybe like doing this top part all pink
and then cutting the sides real short
maybe that would look pretty cool cuz I
mean if I if I have to live with this
for months which I will have to live
with it for many months but I'm a man of
my word I'll
I may not do the full head cuz I'm gonna
consult I've got a professional studio
but I mean if I if you guys want me to
do the full head let me know in the
comments down below if you want me to do
the full head or a styled straight down
like here up all this top long part all
pink either way I'm gonna be rocking
pink hair for a long time just thank you
guys so much for everything you've done
for me thank you for supporting me for
so long and thank you for supporting the
charity efforts thanks for letting me
know I actually make you laugh sometimes
like I hardly ever get feedback like
that it's so touching to see it so
sincerely thank you guys one and all you
can check out the full video down the
description below also subscribe to the
fine brothers they're great guys I've
met them many times spoken with in
person they're great guys and hey thank
you to everyone that was in this video
really appreciate it thanks again
everybody and as always I will see you
in the next video